let the arguments commence so um this is
something I've been meaning to talk
about and an animation junkie for a long
time and it kept sort of slipping off my
radar it came back now because now I've
got the C space cowboy podcast going
where I'm revisiting Cowboy Bebop and
one of the things that I have to account
for when I talk about my reviews of
those episodes is that I'm watching the
dubbed episodes I'm not watching the
subtitled episodes um and I didn't go
into a ton of detail as to why I make
that call but I kind of want to do that
here
because I put a lot of thought into the
whole argument of dubbed versus
subtitled and I watched dubbed anime I'm
not ashamed of that I have no shame in
that and more to the point I think
that's the better way to watch it and
I'm going to explain why now first thing
I'm gonna say is everything that I am
about to say about subtitles vs dubs is
specific to anime and animation in
general I do not believe that you should
watch live-action movies dubbed not for
the obvious reason which is that it's
way more obvious that the mouths aren't
syncing up that's actually not that much
of a problem in anime because the mouths
usually just have generic movements
anyways and they don't even perfectly
sync up with the original Japanese a lot
of the time so that's not so much an
issue there but the big thing with why I
will not watch a dubbed live-action
movie is I cannot expect that an actor
in a booth reading a translated script
is going to be able to evoke the same
motion that an actor on set in that
moment working in that environment was
able to get and I say that even
understanding and knowing enough about
movies to know you know 80
a lot of times and actors depending on
where the thing is set especially any
exterior scenes often have to read of
their own lines but if it's the actor
who did it originally they can pull from
their own experience and they're
remembering of being there they have the
ability to recreate that I just don't
think you can get the same performance
out of a guy in the out of a guy in a
booth that somebody who was on set could
it possibly given however what we're
talking about animation the original was
also just the guy in a booth which means
that at least that big concern for me
doesn't exist in anime so allow me to
talk a little bit about the pluses and
minuses of dubbing and subbing with
anime my eye out for dubs pretty much
every time I actually don't see a lot of
advantage in subtitles unless you are
somebody who is trying to learn Japanese
and you want to hear it more and you
just need the subs like as a guide for
wait what was that oh that's right like
okay sure
that circumstance maybe but other than
that you know it's the weirdest argument
for me is is people who go well I want
to hear it in its original language I
want to hear it as the filmmaker
intended sounds good but I'm also pretty
sure the filmmaker didn't intend you to
be staring at the bottom two inches of
the screen and I think that detracts a
heck of a lot more from what you are
supposed to be focusing on than the fact
that the language is different than it
was originally like that's an argument I
will never get I get hung up with the
same thing with with manga when people
like say oh the only way to read manga
are the ones that are printed right to
left as in the original Japanese except
they're also reading one that's been
translated so again unless you're
reading in the original Japanese why
would you do that because you're the
in Japanese that it's that they read
right to left is because that's the
direction they read their language as
well so for you as an American to read
the book right to left but still read
the captions left to right it's
completely disorienting it's not the
original intention of it you're just
there just being a snob at that point
you're trying to act like you're being
more authentic when you're just making
the experience weird and awkward but
that's just a minor tangent of manga off
of that point that just bugs me but
beyond that ultimately the big thing for
me the only reason that I will ever go
with subtitles in an anime is if the dub
sucks
and sometimes the dub sucks one of my
favorite anime movies I love the ghost
in the shell' it's it's not my number
one anymore but it was for a long time I
love that movie to death and I cannot
watch it dubbed the dub is terrible it's
just a flat unengaging boring voiceover
it's just bad and there's a couple of
others escaflowne I tend to favor the
subtitles because I don't like the dub
on a lot of the characters but the thing
is escaflowne ghost in the shell' and
certainly things that predate them
things being brought over to a metaphor
American audiences from Japan were it
was treated as a niche product it was
treated very much as a veil like
whatever we give them just get some
voices on and get it out there there
wasn't a heck of a lot of care put into
the voice acting of anime through the
80s and much of the 90s once we started
to get into the 2000s actually around
the time Cowboy Bebop started to make it
over here we started to get more care
put in
to it and there were people working on
these dubs who were working harder to
have decent performances than this and
at this point like I can't remember the
last time that I saw a an anime film
with a lousy dub I honestly don't
remember what the last one was now I
mean again bear in mind while I enjoy
anime I'm not like deep it's not I'm I
always hesitate to call myself an anime
fan not because I'm not a fan of anime I
am but generally when people label
themselves anime fans they like can
start rattling off you know all these
characters and all these shows that I'd
never seen so you know it's just the
depth of expectation when someone calls
themselves an anime fan but I watch a
decent amount of it I do not remember
the last time I saw it flat out bad dub
it's been years it's been decades it's
so I don't see the value in watching an
anime with subtitles it's distracting
and in a way that I think is way more
distracting than anything that dub could
be again unless the dub is absolute crap
because bringing it back to ghost in the
shell' I love that movie pretty much
immediately but I also had to watch it
twice basically back-to-back to get the
proper experience I had to watch it once
reading it because the there was there's
some anime where the dialogue doesn't
matter as much or like there's little
snippets and then there's a lot of
action goes to the shells of really
heady movie what they talk about is
important and it matters to the plots of
the themes to the characters so you need
to be paying attention and so I had to
watch twice once reading it and then a
second time have now basically knowing
it just glancing down like oh right
that's what they're talking about and
then properly watching and you know you
can make an argument all well that
forces you to have a deeper experience I
shouldn't be forced to see something
twice to get the
parents that I can get out of watching
most other things once if I watch
something a second time I wanted to be
because I want to see it a second time
not because I need to because I feel
like I didn't get the proper experience
yet so for those reasons I will always
always favor dubs now I don't mean to
come across as a jerk and I think I'm I
may have risked doing so because I'm
sure there are people out there who
prefer subtitles but if your reason for
preferring subtitles is something other
than I have what I've mentioned please
let me know because I don't I don't
understand I don't understand what you
gain from reading subtitles as opposed
to getting able to actually drink in the
visuals and just hear the words as
opposed to having to work overtime to
try and follow what's going on so
whatever your thoughts on this and
absolutely if you disagree with me
please explain to me so I can try and
make sense cuz I still see I still see
it being an argument I don't even
understand how it's an argument anymore
I'm not saying like take away original
Japanese and subtitles as an option on
like DVDs which let's be honest is how
most of us see these movies in the first
place these things almost never less
it's a Miyazaki movie it never gets a
wide theatrical release in the US so I'm
not saying like don't give them the
option it's there on the DVDs if that's
what you want go ahead and watch it I
just I don't get it if someone can't
explain it to me I'd love to hear it cuz
I just again unless the dub sucks I I
don't I don't get it so those are my
thoughts on watching animes with
subtitles versus watching animes that
are dubbed oh you know I'll caveat one
other thing I none of this really
applies to people who watch things that
like I as I understand it some services
for anime like I don't know crunchyroll
maybe some other ones they basically get
they people see them stream
those services and a dub is not yet
available like it's much easier to get a
translation and subtitle it because we
do a dub you got it you got a write the
translation you got to get actors and
you got ahead of it you got to do all
this stuff so people who want to see
these shows as quick to the original
Japanese airdate and they are willing to
accept subtitles in order to do that
that much I get I get that that's about
it though so whatever your thoughts are
drop something down the comments let's
talk about it there's a whole bunch of
stuff to do there's buttons and there's
links including on to my patreon check
them out if you feel like it and in any
case folks remember you're the council I
just run the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]